nasa's goddard space flight center in
greenbelt maryland
nasim rangwala project scientist for the
sophia mission
and nasa ames research center silicon
valley
california we also have a special guest
today sarah noble
lunar scientist at nasa headquarters
and with that let's get started paul
thank you felicia it's great to be
making this announcement today several
studies have shown that water on the
moon's surface
is in its permanently shadowed craters
today
we are announcing that for the first
time water has been
confirmed to be present on a sunlit
surface of the moon
this is exciting because the expectation
is that any water present on a sunlit
surface of the moon
would not survive the lunar day this
discovery reveals that water
might be distributed across the lunar
surface and not limited to the cold
shadowed places near the lunar poles
where we have previously discovered
water ice the discovery was made with
sophia
nasa's airborne observatory which flies
a 100 inch or
2.5 meter telescope high in the earth's
atmosphere
the study of the universe in the far
infrared part of the electromagnetic
spectrum
the water molecule consists of two atoms
of hydrogen and one ounce of oxygen
sometimes water is called h2o
previous observations detected hydrogen
through hydration on the lunar surface
sophia's infrared spectrometer was able
to identify the chemical fingerprint
unique to the water molecule showing
that the previously detected hydrogen is
in a water molecule
and not in some other kind of hydrogen
containing molecule
this discovery raises new questions
about how water is created
and how it can persist in the harsh
airless conditions
of the sunlit lunar circus
this discovery of course is of more than
just scientific interest to nasa
with the artemis program nasa will land
the first woman
and the next man on the moon in 2024
and establish a sustainable human
presence by the end of the decade
at the moon we will prepare for human
exploration of waters
water is a precious resource in space
we want to know everything we can about
water on the moon
one of the things we don't know yet is
whether
the water detected by sophia on a sunlit
surface
is accessible for use of the resource
with that introduction i'm now going to
turn it over to casey hannibal
who is the lead author of the paper
published today
reporting this discovery casey
thank you paul so prior to this
discovery for about a decade we knew
that there was some form of hydrogen on
the sunlit surface of the moon
based on previous spectroscopic
observations spacecraft studied the moon
in the infrared
at wavelength of three microns and could
not differentiate between the water
molecules
and their close cousin hydroxyl hydroxyl
is actually the active ingredient in
drain cleaners
hypothetically if drain cleaner were on
the moon
we could not tell the difference between
the drain cleaner and water
using the three micron wavelengths
however if we study the lunar surface at
a wavelength of six microns with sophia
the water molecule has a distinct
chemical fingerprint that hydroxyl does
not have
the six micron fingerprint requires the
bond between two hydrogen atoms and one
oxygen atom
that only exists in the water molecule
h2o
sophia's unique position above most of
the water in the earth's atmosphere
allowed us to look for the six micron
single print on the sunlit moon
this observation finally allowed us to
definitively determine that
water molecules are present on this on
the surface of the moon
we found the water in the moon's
southern hemisphere at clavius crater
and its surrounding region
clavius is one of the largest craters
visible from earth
at this location the data reveal a water
concentration of about 100
to 400 parts per million that's roughly
equivalent to a 12 oz bottle of water
within a cubic meter of volume
of lunar soil but our observations with
sophia only sense the very surface of
the moon
to be clear this is not puddles of water
but instead water molecules that are so
spread apart that they do not form
ice or liquid water the water that we
observe has two potential sources
it could be either from the solar wing
or micrometeorite
the solar wind delivers hydrogen to the
lunar surface that reacts with oxygen in
the soil and forms hydroxyl
during micrometeorite impacts on the
moon this pre-existing hydroxyl can be
converted into water by
combining two hydroxyl molecules
together in the high temperatures from
the impact
many of these same micrometeorites may
also contain water of their own
that can transfer to the moon
what's interesting is that without a
thick lunar atmosphere
water on any hot sunlit surface of the
moon
should be lost to space or find its way
to the lunar polar cold trip
yet somehow we're still seeing it on a
sunlit moon
we think the water is trapped within
glass seeds in the soil that forms
during the micrometer
impact these glass seeds are about the
size of a pencil tip and protect the
water from a harsh lunar environment
understanding the source of water and
its retention helps piece together the
broader history and role
water plays in the inner solar system
and on other airless bodies like
asteroids
and may have implications for human
exploration our next speaker is jacob
lucha
jacob thank you casey
the sophia results discussed today are
very exciting for us in
human exploration this discovery is a
great example
of science and human exploration working
hand in hand
this is a multi-disciplined science
approach to collect data that will
also help enable human exploration
understanding where the water is on the
moon will help us prepare to send
astronauts to lunar south pole
with our artemis program but you might
ask why does water matter to artemis
well it's far easier to travel when you
don't have to carry
everything with you that you might need
for the entire trip
for instance here on earth if you can
depend on resources throughout your trip
and at your destination
uh things you might get at a gas station
or a restaurant or hotels or campsites
then you can be much more efficient with
what you pack
if it comes down to packing water or
your favorite book to read
well you'll have to take the water to
survive
water is extremely critical for deep
space exploration
it's a resource of direct value for our
astronauts
water can be turned into oxygen for them
to breathe it could be a fuel supply
that they use later
but obviously it can be water they can
drink or you could use it for other
purposes
but water is heavy and therefore it's
expensive to launch from the surface of
the earth
anytime we don't need to pack water for
our trip we have an opportunity to
take other useful items with us for
instance payloads to do more science
so you can imagine easily being able to
use water that is already at the moon
would be a big help for us in exploring
the moon with our astro
we know there's water at the moon but we
don't know exactly how accessible lunar
water is
for our future explorers knowing where
we can find water is a good first step
but we need to know more about the water
to understand if and how we can use it
for both science and exploration
we know that water exists in some of the
darkest and coldest locations on the
moon
inside craters that have never seen
sunlight
those cold and dark environments are
difficult to reach and they can be even
harder to work in for long periods of
time
so finding water that's easier to reach
is really important to us this could
involve finding easier to reach small
craters that have the water
or as these sofia results show
that we can find water outside of these
craters
understanding the state in which the
water exists is quite important
if it's locked into the glass beads as
casey mentioned it may require more
energy to extract it
if the water's mixed up in the soil it
might be a little easier
regardless knowing more about that water
how it gets there
the form in which it's present how much
of it exists
whether it moves around all of this is
very useful information for planning
possible resource utilization on the
moon
it's also important to understand how
stable the water is
and how easily disturbed or lost it
might be
as well as whether or not it might be
replenished over time
or if it's lost for good from the
location once we sample or use it
future missions like nasa's volatiles
investigating polar exploration rover or
viper
will be looking for water directly on
the surface and up to a meter below the
surface
to help make the first water resource
maps of the moon
you can see that this exciting discovery
leads to many new questions about water
on the moon
in our future science and exploration
activities and now we'll hear from
nassim rangwala sophia's project
scientist
thanks jacob as paul mentioned sophia is
an airborne observatory
by flying at high altitudes up to 45 000
feet sophia is able to get above 99.9
of the water vapor in earth's atmosphere
that is blocking the infrared light from
space
specifically for this discovery sophia
allowed us to detect water
on the sunlit surface of the moon
without contamination
from terrestrial water sofia carries an
instrument
that is able to pick up the specific
wavelength
unique to water molecules at 6.1 microns
as you heard from casey in fact
sophia is currently the only telescope
on or off this world that can provide
remote access to this unique chemical
fingerprint of water
at 6.1 microns normally
we study distant and much dimmer objects
like black holes star clusters and
galaxies
this was actually the first time sophia
observed the moon
and we did it as a test case
because the questions surrounding the
moon's water were so compelling
they decided to use the observatory in a
way not previously
imagined so in august of 2018
we decided to try a test observation on
the moon
this discovery was made while we were
flying over nevada
on our way back to our home base in
palmdale california
what was essentially a test far exceeded
our expectations
now that we know we can do this and
given the importance of
understanding the distribution of water
on the moon and the origin of water in
our solar system
we are planning more flights with sofia
to collect
more data we are very excited that these
follow-up observations
will look for water in more sunlit
locations to better
understand how water is created stored
and moves across the lunar surface over
time
these observations will add to the data
that nasa's next moon rover
the viper mission will collect to create
the first water resource map of the moon
back to you paul thanks nasim
nasa's space observatories allow us to
study the universe
in ways that are impossible from the
ground
and although sofia is not a space
observatory
it's an airborne observatory it does
allow us a view of the universe in the
far infrared
that is impossible from the ground
because the water vapor in the earth's
atmosphere
blocks this part of the electromagnetic
spectrum
today we are announcing an important
discovery by sofia
that the previously detected hydrogen on
the sunlit surface of the moon
is located in water molecules
this discovery raises new questions
about how water is
created on the surface of the moon and
how it can persist
in the harsh airless sunlit conditions
of the lunar surface knowing how much
water is on the moon
and how we might be able to use it in
the future
supports nasa's long-term human
exploration goals into deep space
nasa will continue to leverage all of
his assets
including sofia the world's premier
airborne observatory
to contribute to the success of the
artemis mission and nasa's human
exploration program
alicia thanks paul
media resources for this announcement is
available on nasa.gov
sophia and can also be found on our
press release
we will now start the question and
answer session sarah noble
headquarter lunar scientist will also be
joining us to cover your questions
we will limit everyone to one question
our operator should identify you
but if not please identify yourself your
media affiliation
and then direct your question to a
specific panelist if possible
for those dialing in push star 1 keys on
your phone to be placed into queue
to ask a question using twitter please
use the hashtag
asknasa and with that
let's begin let's start with jeff faust
from space news
to the moon whether they are orbiters or
some of the the landers beyond
obviously the viper rover might be used
to better characterize
the water signal that you saw with
sophia is there anything
currently on the books that would help
in that regard thanks
this is jacob i'm sorry we missed the
very beginning of your question
um could you maybe restate it please
sure let me let me try and summarize uh
are any of the upcoming missions whether
they are orbiters or
landers including payloads on clip
slanders
uh useful in helping to better
characterize the water signal you saw
with sophia
thanks yeah i can
i can give you a little background on on
some additional clips capabilities that
we're looking at
uh the the clips flights or commercial
lunar payload services
will leverage capabilities of industry
partners to quickly deliver scientific
instruments technology demonstrations to
the moon
as part of that nasa will be sending
dozens of science investigations and
technology experiments to the surface
that will help us find and potentially
extract later
resources on the moon so just an example
of some of these
that we're looking at moving forward one
would be the mass spectrometer observing
observing lunar operations or m solo
and solo will identify low molecular
weight volatiles
it can be installed to either measure
the lunar exosphere
or even things like spacecraft
outgassing and contamination because we
also want to understand what our
presence might be doing to the the water
and the
the precious volatiles there so data
gathered from m solo
will help determine the composition and
concentration
of these potentially accessible
resources another example would be a
neutron spectrometer system
nss nss will search for indications of
water ice near the lunar surface
by measuring how much hydrogen bearing
materials are at a landing site
and help determine the overall bulk
composition of the regolith around it
another example would be the near
infrared volatile
spectrometer or nervus nervus will
measure surface and subsurface hydration
carbon dioxide methane all resources
that could potentially be
mined from the moon and used by our
future explorers
they also help map surface temperature
changes at the landing site
and we mentioned uh we mentioned viper
earlier
we also have another activity that will
be going ahead of viper
nasa's awarded eclipse provider uh
intuitive machines attacks
in order to fly the polar resources ice
mining experiment or prime
one so prime one is a drill
combined with a mass spectrometer and
we'll be heading to the moon
in late 2022. so this is a precursor
uh drill and it will
fly with which will fly
it is a precursor to the trident drill
that's going to fly with m solo on viper
so this is going to give us an example
of how exactly to use the more
enabled viper mission when we get it
there so we do have a series of
activities and payloads that are already
set up to help us start measuring this
and understand more about the
the environment and the volatiles there
great thank you uh next question is
marcia dunn from ap
oh sorry yes marshalltown from ap yes hi
can you hear me hello
yes um yes this is for um the lead
author um
ms hunnabal uh could you tell me please
um
how much you know over how much area of
the moon
did you detect these molecules
the water molecules i'm going to give
some sense of
how vast an area how small an area and
how many molecules are we actually
talking about in the thousands million
i'm just trying to get a handle on how
big and how much
yeah so the clavius crater is the
largest
crater observed from the earth but it's
not
uh it's not that big when we looked at
the moon
our observations extended from about
a 65 sorry a 50 degree
latitude down to about 75 degrees in
latitude on the moon
so we only covered a few degrees
um on the moon but also the abundances
that we measured are only 100 to 400 ppm
of water which is not a lot like i said
these water molecules are not
interacting with each other they are
individual molecules incorporated into
these glass beads so they're not in a
form of ice
or liquid
thank you
next question we have david curley from
the discovery channel
thanks for uh taking the question um you
kind of touched on it there
i mean this is an amazing discovery but
how much is there uh will it matter will
it
provide for astronauts if
we need to mine it thank you
casey i think um maybe you can reiterate
the amount of water
yeah so the amount of water is um
roughly equivalent to a
12 ounce bottle of water within a cubic
liter of
lunar soil but this instead of being at
a volume this
is spread across the surface of the moon
whether or not it's usable for mining i
will turn over to jacob
yeah thanks casey and this is you know
this is the
the core part to the question right and
i think several of us
hinted at this is that we really need to
understand more about the water that's
present
so we need to understand what form it's
in
uh we need to understand how much of it
there is and
this complement of approaches of
measurements that we can make
some of them look at just at the surface
some can look deeper
below the surface some see water
in different forms than in other forms
we need to gain that
broad picture of what the resource stock
really is
at the south polar region we also need
to understand
how we can not only approach it as a
resource but how we can also use it as
a science resource because that ice
also carries with it much information
about
evolution of the solar system evolution
of the sun evolution of the moon earth
system
uh so you know it's hard to answer the
question straight up is this discovery
going to provide us with enough water
to do anything specific it's part of a
process
in moving forward and understanding
volatiles and volatile cycles on the
moon
and this is an important discovery
because now we know that that water does
exist
outside of some of these places in these
dark craters that are really hard to get
into and really hard to operate in
so this might be an avenue for us to to
get to water a little bit easier
thank you next
i believe we have joey roulette from
reuters
hey a question for paul and jacob um
kind of similar to what was asked before
but what will it take to know whether
the water molecules can be turned into
usable resources to support
um the artemis program like either
drinkable water
ingredients for rocket fuel etc do you
think we'll know
this from more remote observations or
will we have to rely on future
you know robots or probes on the ground
thanks
i can give my uh my first shout out
answering that question
um you know we already lifted off um a
handful of
of additional payloads that are uh
planned to go to the lunar surface
i think it's critical uh that we combine
remote observation which can give us the
broad
context so you know observations from
from sofia coupled with other uh
observations that look more broadly at
the moon can tell us regionally
where we see those signatures but then
we need to also get on the ground
and sample so we have as i mentioned the
um viper mission is heading that way
and you know i hope that you can see
that this is kind of an iterative
approach
so for instance we're sending the prime
one drill to help us understand better
how to approach it when we get viper
there that's a more capable vehicle
so you know answering the question
exactly when we'll know
is difficult what i can say is that
from a in situ resource utilization
perspective
uh you know we have multiple approaches
to extracting the water
multiple activities that are underway
and as we learn more we'll know better
which of those to develop further
so that we can follow that approach and
it may be that there's multiple
approaches uh because the water be in
different forms in different places it
may be more accessible
we also again have to learn um justly
going up to the water
we're going to be disruptive to it to
the point we then can't use it
so you know each one of these lessons
helps us learn
better how to query the lunar
environment the lunar surface
on our next step moving forward
thank you next we have ken chang from
the new york times
kenneth
oh goodness are you on
okay before we go back to kenneth um
let's go ahead and take some
ask nasa questions if you would like to
ask a question using twitter please use
the hashtag
asknasa so we have a question from liam
parker
asking what volume of water is found and
does it suggest life
may have been present on the moon
previously
sarah can you talk about that
sure so we covered a little bit about
how much water is there it's not a lot
and it's also water by itself is really
not enough there are other
ingredients necessary for life and the
moon is frankly
a really harsh place the radiation
environment
the lack of an atmosphere there are lots
of reasons we can
talk about that where where life is just
not a thing that they think could have
ever been
possible
thank you let's try to jump back to the
q
a dennis are you available
yes can you hear me now yes sorry about
that
um i just wanted to clarify a few things
in 2009 there was data from changi r1 uh
about water in the sunlit areas is this
is confirmation that
confirming that it's water and not
hydroxyl but otherwise similar
and was there a confirmation of water
in the deep craters from the l across or
is also that invigorating
between h2o and hydroxyl
hi this is casey so i can take the first
part of that
the observation from 2009 with m cube on
the lunar surface were of the three
micron band which could not distinguish
between hydroxyl and
water molecules what our detection today
on the sunlit moon is saying is that at
least part of what end tube detected
is in the form of molecular water
um maybe somebody else can make the elk
cross part
sure let me let me jump in l cross did
in fact find
some water but that was of course
looking in a permanently shadowed region
so the difference here is that we're now
seeing it in sunlight as well
great thank you next we have christopher
covkians
from sky news canada
yes can you hear me okay yes
okay yeah it's kokino so it's an odd
name
um first congratulations to the team um
and then a question about the the map
the water map uh of clavius
um and did you see any evidence of
movement of these molecules over time in
other words these
apparent glass beads that are containing
these straight water molecules are they
breaking down
are they moving at all due to solar wind
or micro meteorite impacts so
was this do you see do you see a process
is the map dynamic at all or or
is that something to look for in future
missions
this is casey yeah that is definitely
something that we are going to be
looking for
uh moving forward with continuing
observations with sophia
with the current data if not
in time of one location at one time
on the moon so we need in order to
understand the mobility of water and if
it's moving
and how it's really stored we need more
observations of different lunar phases
to really be able to get
at that mobility problem of water
thank you next we have leo and wright
from irish tv
uh thanks very much one thing about this
the source of this
water you mentioned one possibility as
glass beads on the surface being impact
uh by the solar wind now i'm afraid
with this question but i was actually in
the science support room in the mission
control center
during apollo 17 when they were at
shorty crater
and i will never forget the scenes in
that room when they found
orange soil because everybody in the
room believed that that meant
water and they were devastated many of
them
told their scientists when they
discovered well
maybe it wasn't um i'm wondering could
could those be exactly the beads that
you're talking about
hi this is casey so those are actually
different kinds of beads those are
volcanic
beads that were erupted during a
volcanic process on the moon
that the glass beads that we're talking
about are
little beads that form when a
micrometeorite impacts the moon and
melts part of the lunar surface
it melts it and cut and could either
deliver the water or
form water from pre-existing hydroxyl
which then
cools to form a little what we are
calling little glass beads
so there's the ones that they found on
apollo and the ones that we're talking
about here
are different beads we do think that the
apollo glass glasses like apollo sound
may concentrate water and hopefully
we can do observations of the apollo 17
site to
possibly detect water at that location
with sophia
and if i may chase and ask a follow-up
um i'm particularly interested
in the instrument that you were using
it's my understanding that it was
designed and built
by the andor company in belfast in
northern ireland is that correct
i'm going to pass this one on to naseem